[Musique]
avec la pandémie la mondialisation a
bien souvent été pointé du doigt comme
étant en partie responsable les échanges
commerciaux le trafic aérien ont
forcément favorisés ou le transport du
virus de territoire en territoire en
2019 à quelques mois deux apparitions du
coc vide le volume mondial total
d'exportations de biens et de services
et et de 24000 795 milliards de dollars
et de 24 mille trois cent douze
milliards de dollars des importations
sacré chiffres en 2020 il y a bien sûr
eu déconfinement successifs et autres
restrictions sanitaires sur toute la
planète qui ont eu un impact d'à peine 9
2%
et oui l'économie a continué à tourner
la problématique d'une mondialisation
autrement voire d'une démondialisation
et donc d'une baisse strict des
importations et relocalisation de la
production se pose alors que la fin de
la pandémie pourrait approcher grâce à
la vaccination surtout quand on voit
qu'un simple porte containers bloquant
le canal de suez a réussi à mettre à
l'arrêt 10% du commerce maritime mondial
écoutez 5 à 8 milliards par jour faisons
également grimper en flèche le prix du
pétrole
et oui la mondialisation ça tient
finalement à peu de choses en tout cas
cette année on ne prend pas vraiment le
chemin d'une démondialisation
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
table déjà sur un rebond des échanges de
plus de 7% en 2021
[Musique]